hallo deutsch schule punkt ch hören und
nachsprechen lektion 12 hört zu und
spricht nach
wie viel
kostet ein bier wie viel kostet ein bier
ein bier kostet 5 franken 70 ein bier
kostet 5 franken 70
wie
kostet ein orangensaft wie viel kostet
ein orangensaft
orangensaft kostet 4 franken 50
saft kostet 4 franken 50
was möchten sie bestellen
ich nehme ein stück kuchen bitte ich
nehme ein stück kuchen bitte was möchten
sie trinken was
sie trinken ich trinke ein
ohne kohlensäure bitte ich trinke ein
wasser ohne kohlensäure bitte was
sie gern was hätten sie gern
ich hätte gern einen kaffee mit milch
und zucker bitte ich hätte
einen kaffee mit milch und zucker bitte
wie trinken sie ihren kaffee trinken sie
ihren kaffee
einen kaffee schwarz bitte ich trinke
viel schwarz bitte was
möchten sie essen was möchten sie essen
ich mir
fruchtsalat bitte ich nehme
fruchtsalat bitte möchtest du einen
kaffee
möchtest du einen kaffee ja gern ja gern
nein danke nein danke möchten sie etwas
essen möchten sie etwas essen ja gern
ich möchte den käse tost bitte ja gern
käse tost bitte nein
ich habe keinen hunger nein
danke ich habe keinen hunger möchten sie
etwas trinken möchten sie etwas trinken
ja gern ich möchte eine tasse tee bitte
nein danke ich habe keinen durst
okay ich habe keinen durst bezahlen sie
zusammen oder getrennt
bezahlen sie zusammen oder getrennt
alles zusammen bitte alles zusammen
bitte getrennt bitte getrennt bitte ich
bezahle
orangensaft ich bezahle den orangensaft
ich bezahle den
spaghetti und das bier ich bezahle
spaghetti und das bier ich nehme einen
kaffee ich nehme einen kaffee nimmst du
auch einen kaffee nimmst du auch einen
kaffee er sie es nimmt einen orangensaft
es nimmt einen orangensaft
wir nehmen eine flasche wasser
wir nehmen eine flasche wasser nimmt
auch eine flasche wasser nimmt
auch eine flasche wasser sie nehmen eine
flasche wein
in eine flasche wein
ich mag keinen
ich mag
magst du fisch magst du fisch er sie es
mag café er sie es marktcafé wir mögen
kein fleisch
wir mögen kein fleisch
mögt ihr fleisch mögt ihr fleisch
si
gemüse ich habe hunger
ich habe hunger
hast du durst hast du durst er sie es
hat die rechnung er sie es hat die
rechnung
wir
einen sohn wir haben einen sohn
habt ihr kinder habt ihr kinder sie
haben keinen frischen fruchtsaft sie
haben keinen frischen fruchtsaft hat dir
das video gefallen abonniere unseren
kanal habt ihr das video gefallen
abonniere unseren kanal hat dir das
video gefallen abonniere unseren kanal